den hammer mit sander ich jetzt hier
hinten irgendwann jackpot abzugreifen
da kommt auf mich zu ich habe auch nie
gewollt oder computer
ich hab eigentlich extra geht's jetzt
die man jetzt sagen jetzt hängt es ja
von klein
hallo an alle zu einer weiteren pvp und
schlank
zusammen mit dem sondern konkreter und
mir gibt's jetzt ein team und zwar ist
das eine art capture the flag sozusagen
wir müssen jetzt ein paar checkpoint
suchen
es gab nach müssen um praktisch ich gebe
auf den rechten hier irgendwo in der
nähe gehe auf den link dann sollten sich
zudem auf einigen jahr würdigkeit sagen
sondern wir beide am besten gegen haben
auf dem eigenen da wohl warten weil den
kennen wir uns einig sind schlecht von
daher passt es gut er sollte opel
sollten gehalten oder gleich zum
nächsten mal ich glaube nichts weiteren
bestenfalls main finden
ich hab' ich habe vorhin hier irgendwo
chefs aber auch schon ein römer gehauen
jammern ich habe auch schon ein hier
ich nehme mir neben 1 ich habe auch kein
einer sind bei mir hat's grad
okay ich bin wieder drauf hätte mich
doch hört ja alles gut wir sind zu zweit
da ich muss auf dem weg von stehen
bleiben
keine gute figur
stimmt die feige sau muss man muss
auftakt stehen bleiben
du musst ein stehendes fenster wieder
einmal rüber gelaufen einfach nur mehr
du musst du musst darauf stehen bis zu
zwei personen das prinzip ankommt
erklärt leute wir müssen nämlich er noch
kurz erzählen worum es hier geht wir
kriegen den vier checkpoint wir müssen
die checker nach goldnuggets geht dann
kriegen wir gold nuggets los 21 wenn wir
die goldnuggets haben könnte gold lag
jetzt auch einen ton finden
leute ich stehe jetzt auf diesen link ad
drau dass das scheint unser das ist
einfach dass das spielprinzip man muss
einfach stehen am besten gelaufen das
und dann ändern sich die farben von gold
zu
dhaka collins zweiten checkpoint enten
dehner und bass er will kommen zu euch
leider der fall weglaufen
ja nein der der luchs darüber
hundertprozentig dass wir hier gucken
was hier so eine sache ist aber ich habe
hier drauf stehen bleiben ja ich bin
noch hier in den check kann ein angebot
hat kann man muss sich steht wenn man
kann auch weggehen luca das ist der ist
fabian drei checkpoints leute ich hab
nur 1 1 gelungen
ok also wir kriegen einen gold wenn wir
das haben ich habe gerade auch in gott
ich habe gut angespielt einfach euren
spieler verloren kommt kommen wie rechts
komm mit ich will nicht ein bisschen
verteidigen einfach hier den ja aber wir
haben hier noch eine kampagne teilnehmen
ach so ja und würdigte goldner gibt ja
auch meist das jetzt unser da kommen sie
da kommen sie da kommen sie hinterher
wieder goldmarkts gleich wieder drei
eingenommen
nein [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] aber ich komme
wieder ziemlich heftig kommt zu dir
ich habe einen gold wie ich weiß ich
warum platz ja das haben wir gekriegt
weil wir drei checkpoints eingenommen
hatten
ach so ja gut jetzt am gehalt guckte
seinen am 31
wieder gold wir brauchen 32 goldnuggets
um das spiel zu gewinnen und das hat der
bühne wieder gold nicht jeder noch ist
jetzt noch ein gold wahrscheinlich
kriegt ja ja ich hab verloren
ich hab ich mir krieg verdampft
niedergeschlagen haben herr sauber
sauber den hut ich habe mich verlor
verlaufen verloren
ich gehe dann eben links gucken und da
alles schnell sollen wir die nuggets im
inventar behalten einfach nur in der
mitte ist komme ich glaube hier ist ein
jackpot
was ist eigentlich werden wenn wir
unsere holzschwertern kaputt ist dann
glaube ich können wir neue kaufen für
die goldene jetzt aber wieder
das problem die sind zu zweit alle
richtig trainiert wie gut ich fasse
kriegt gerade die dorf nur zwei nämlich
nicht für merck
wir müssen länger drauf bleiben auf dem
chip online da ist der gehört uns
scheiße jetzt will er wieder einleben
ich glaube die nachbarn stehen versteht
die darauf setzt außenrum versuchte
hinzukriegen direkt bei und komme ich
bin hinter dir in deiner erfolgreich
innovative oder auch lieber nicht ich
die auf den jackpot wieder um gold
da kannst du rettest
den hammer mit sonder check von
abzugreifen
da kommt auf mich zu ich werfe ich habe
auf ihn geworfen oder computer gleich
wieder auf drei bei uns bist du denn ich
sehe ich gar nicht er ich glaube die
ganze zeit extra dann nicht wo ihr seid
wenn ihr den job ich mit den anderen
weil jetzt hab ich grad wieder
eingenommen und jetzt gehen wir wieder
gleich gold ich habe gerade zwei gold-
ich stets bei euch wenigstens einmal
geschlagen
ich habe nur zwei herzen da hab ich
angst gehabt und dann bin ich weg
gerannt die kosten bei dir ich bin
bereit ich bin bei dir ich habe vor
lange jetzt überlebt
links
aber wie viele ideen hatten die hier
überhaupt nein die haben noch gar keins
glaube ich hab drei gibt es beim 39
wir sind voll gut aber jetzt achtung
beim 3 1 vorsprung weil ich übernehme
den linken auf den rechten
wir müssen zusammen ich komme jetzt also
ich hab jetzt ein von denen so ein hab
ich ja ich habe einen genommen da suche
ich noch einen zweiten bei denen base zu
holen
alte hat diesen zu zweit machen ein
bisschen bist du denn jetzt ich finde
dich nicht ich bin am rechten spot
gewesen ich hab den kindgerechten ein
wieder besucht aber euch die frau in
solchen momenten hätte ich gern den
amtierende einfach zutage hysterisch
rumschreit kombination jetzt kann auch
seinen eingenommen ja genau
jede menge weiß wie hau ab du bist du
doch stückchen weiter vor zum nächsten
gehen zum zum einnehmen hinten kommt er
wieder ein neues super rechts gegangen
so passt die apple habe ich ich hab
gerade die daten schenkt man
kutschfahrten holstein schwert der komme
er ins heck wir haben drei stück wir
müssen auf jeden fall was unternehmen
wir müssen handeln
ja wir brauchen anwender von euch stirbt
alles zusammenschmeißen für einen start
der was ich bin jetzt ich will in seinen
links gekommen
ich habe vier punkte kann ich ein leben
der mann in punkt 1
hast du aber ich glaube die kommen
überlegen sie kommen überlegen sie
kommen ganz weit über links luca ich
lasse ich lassen einfach laufen gerade
weil ich dir den checkpoint nehmen also
wir sollten am besten auch zum zweiten
lauf nicht ob das wären relativ
interessant bei der bin bei dir ich bin
tot
du kannst dich bei mir sein doch noch
geschafft wirklich leicht wieder als
kommission seinem basic behindert geht
gar nicht
help you auf der schon tot herkomme ist
ein schwert ist kaputt tom hat gar kein
links mehr gar keinen hut mehr
ich hab auch martin schwerdt mir ich
glaube jetzt einfach laufen hatte ich
bis jetzt habe viel gold jeder na ja
aber wir haben trotzdem nur zwei
checkpoints das richtig scheiße - nein
wir haben gleich drei wieder in graphit
einen dritten ein ja cool ich bin es
einfach fdp die weg lockt okay weil ich
aber kein schwert naja vielleicht sollte
ich nicht so viele kühe am anfang
tötet haben der hervester gewinnen ich
hab aber noch ob das passiert ich habe
mich voll durch die am 3 ja und gleich
nochmal vier ich bin euch steffen 4
ich glaube den letzten von ihrem tod
diese hier sind alle drei hier sind drei
versucht die anderen einzunehmen
hier sind kommen bei diesen alle drei
von denen ja ich hole mir jetzt ein
stein schwert es geht nicht anders sagt
ich wieder allein
ich habe ja auch kein schwert dann geht
mir dann stolz holzschwert ich hab
eigentlich alexander klein
hier kommt
auch nur bommel bleibt stehen guckt mich
an sie zu schlecht weg das leiden sich
mittelmäßig war für dich selbst beispiel
davis den checkpoint stand die ganze
zeit nenne ich bin auch unterwegs aber
gerade der den ort unterwegs nur bommel
kommt dann war es aber die quote
dies ist eigentlich sollten gleich zu
einem werk an machen also ein
stimmtraining ausrüsten
ich gehe am besten jemand das kann also
ich hab noch achten stein schwert wie
geht es euch so ja ich habe einen nagel
und gar nichts was die etwa an mir
vorbei gerannt ist kommen wir auch
glücklich dass ich auf der platte steht
die gerne beide in mitte ok dann kommen
jetzt von außen so ein bisschen versuche
ich dann da hinten als nehmen das thema
grad drauf diesen grad ganz rechts in
eine platte gläubiger stellen dann
rechts parteien
wieso kann der mich denn töten ich hab
doch einstein schwert nein muss ja im
grunde musst du denn der auf der platte
steht nur unter kicken einmal kommt es
auf die zwei hinter her
locklear ich habe auch erst ein später
gerade geholt naja ich hab mir auch
eingeholtes besitze ich aber nicht nur
vier gold und mich mein altes
holzschwert reingeworfen was kaputt war
okay ich habe ganz noch ein eingenommen
wir haben hier ist ja ja ja das ist aber
kein verband ungarn vierten mal wieder
zeit wandern oder weitermacht alexander
gehst du zu unseren rechten lang ich
zudem vorne
von den gegnern räder kommen zwei da
kommts weiterkommen
aber dann komme ich finde ich nicht okay
glocke zudem wo der aufstand seiner
gesamten laufen immer besser
da man alle beide gekillt sauber.de
natürlich erstmal ne kuh haben hier
eigentlich auch schon stein schwerter
oder verfolgen
luca wird auf das tool losgelösten
checkpoint nein nein ich habe nur
gesehen kurze szene
ich hole jetzt noch ein jackpot den
bauch stehen
evers weg
damit scheint sich gerade jetzt noch zum
letzten teil verliert drei bussen der
letzte ist ja ganz links also die map
map ist gespiegelt musst du bist von
alle drei in der base nicht verletzten
haben alle drei djs jetzt hole ich habe
den letzten acht und gleich an software
direkt wenn es rauskommt kann ich wohl
der vierte war es die roten schon
gewonnen
wir haben gewonnen weißt du warum habt
ihr jeweils gold markets radar
eingeworfen wie reingeworfen fürs spiel
gewinnen
wie viel gold nugget habt ihr 12 7 habe
ich diesen plus 12 10 19
meine sieben hätten widerstand als die
stadt wendig genug kaufte grund scheiße
retten das gold reingeschmissen schönere
welt
dann haben wir jetzt richtig richtig
verschlossen werden
egal einfach reingehen tier töten jetzt
sauber darf jetzt aber noch nicht okay
gut also leute irgendwie ich denke
fertig ja also uns wohl falsch
konzentriert ich glaube wir haben
relativ gut zu euch gesammelt und werden
sie verschwinden sollen und einfach da
gleich schon bezahlen müssen fürs spiel
gewinnen so sieht es richtig unsere tage
anschaut hat wir waren nicht schlecht ja
keine panik ja wir das problem ist ja
nicht wirklich zu viel darauf versteift
wirklich gute sachen zu kaufen der
unternehmen die checkpoints einzelne ich
habe jetzt so gedacht worden
schwer tun ich habe ich nicht gerechnet
so schnell fertig sein aber es macht auf
jeden fall spaß also ich denke an die
druckwellen wir wollten gerade richtig
schöne party machen doch einmal you go
ruft immer die aufnahme ist als lang
wird
also leute haut rein